bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
fois n'est pas coutume je voudrais
remercier personnellement jean castex
s'enquit estelle se serait envolé pour
des vacances bien méritées merci jean
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler de la sphère gamestop
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous ravis de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de ses caches vent de
panique à wall street
comment des internautes ont-ils pu faire
perdre des dizaines de millions de
dollars à des traders chevronnés
peuvent-ils réitéré qu'elle risque à
long terme on va plonger dans cette
émission dans la sphère et gamestop et
la guerre déclarée par une poignée de
boursica de boursicoteurs 2.0 au fonds
d'investissement de wall street et pour
cela en deuxième partie nous serons en
liaison avec anis lajnef ancien trader
c'est une histoire qui fera date la
sphère gamestop fin janvier des petits
investisseurs sont parvenus à se
coordonner sur internet pour faire plier
de grands fonds d'investissements des
hedge funds comme on les appelle que
s'est il passé exactement résumé avec le
tiroir cash d'antoine basse la sphère
gamestop c'est une bonne claque prise
par des fonds d'investissement de wall
street il ya quelques semaines un coup
de poing infligés par des investisseurs
du dimanche des boursicoteurs comme on
les appelle dans les médias qui ont
réussi à faire exploser les prix d'une
action qui a priori n'avait aucune
raison de monter
on va essayer d'être clair et concis en
fait des fonds d'investissement avait
simplement miser sur la déroute d'une
entreprise gamestop donc un pari a
priori logique surtout quand on sait
qu'il s'agit d'une boîte spécialisée
dans la vente physique de jeux vidéo et
que nous sommes en pleine pandémie voire
en confinement dans de nombreux pays et
que le marché du jeu vidéo
se tourne maintenant en majorité vers le
dématérialisé les fonds d'investissement
ont fait ce qu'on appelle de la vente à
découvert
sauf qu environ 5 millions
d'investisseurs particuliers issus du
réseau social reddit se sont mis à
acheter massivement ces fameuses
obligation d'achat gamestop faisant
passer le prix de l'action de 20 dollars
début janvier à près de 400 dollars
occasionnant un bon 2007 100 % au total
et condamnant ainsi les fonds
d'investissement de wall street qui
avait misé sur une baisse à acheter ces
actions au prix fort bien plus élevé que
celui qu'ils avaient prévu et donc à
perdre
selon le spécialiste de données
financières fesf lui partenaires jusqu'à
20 milliards de dollars
battus donc à leur propre jeu et ça
pourrait être seulement 1 des boues
d'autres titres sur lesquels les
hedge-fund de wall street ont misé à la
baisse pourraient être ciblées par ces
fameux boursicoteurs pour blackberry
c'est déjà le cas ce pourrait être le
tour de nokia ou de im si une chaîne de
cinéma américain l'autorité de
régulation de la bourse américaine a de
son côté bien sûr lancé une enquête
méga-événement questionne déjà pas mal
sur le fonctionnement de wall street en
général et aussi sur toutes les
liquidités injectées par la fed à avoir
trop d'argent sur les marchés ou pour
finir par se brûler les ailes
[Musique]
olivier au delà de la leçon de
l'arroseur arrosé quels enseignements
peut-on tirer de cette affaire sur le
fonctionnement de la bourse aujourd'hui
la première chose c'est quelque chose
qui est là depuis longtemps
c'est à dire un vendre à découvert une
action c'est pas nouveau ça date pas de
l'année dernière et là la seule chose
qui diffère d'avancé que on a
aujourd'hui des montants colossaux qui
ont été déversées sur les bourses à 1
par la politique des banques centrales
et que donc il ya des liquidités à
foison et que ces liquidités sont
utilisés pour jouer en bourse dans les
deux sens
d'accord et là ce qui m'amuse beaucoup
c'est c'est le fait on en fasse toute
une affaire on en fasse un problème
d'arroseur arrosé etc
non ce ne sont pas les petits porteurs
qui ont fait qui ont lancé le mouvement
cdti beaucoup plus malins qui sont des
grosses mains et qui ont organisé leur
coup ils ont profité de d'un système si
vous voulez mais ça ça date de la
manipulation de cours' à dater des short
squeeze ça date d'il ya des dizaines
d'années on en a fait enfin moi quand
j'étais trader
il ya de cela trente ans c'est des
choses qu'on faisait déjà donc il n'y a
rien d'extraordinaire à ça et il ne faut
pas considérer ça comme la révolution
des petits contre les gros et c'est non
c'est des gens qui ont organisé leurs
coûts qui ont profité en effet des
réseaux sociaux qui ont profité du fait
que vous avez toute une clientèle de
nouveautrader entre guillemets qui ont
récemment ouvert un compte chez robin
hood et qui se prennent pour des pour
des traders et qui les ont fédéré on va
dire pour réussir leur coup mais
rassurez-vous vous avez quelqu'un qui en
ont bien profité qui ont fait beaucoup
de sous avec pareil des effets de levier
donc c'est aussi immoral à la baisse
qu'à la hausse 1 et donc
et donc qu'ils en ont profité et qui ont
mis à genoux un iphone mais comme comme
on le faisait déjà depuis je vous dis 30
ans donc il ya rien de nouveau sous le
soleil
simplement on en a fait une affaire du
petit contrôle gros et c'est assez
amusant mais pour ceux qui connaissent
vraiment et fonctionnement de la bourse
il ya rien d'étonnant là dedans merci
olivier on passe tout de suite à la
deuxième partie de cette émission et
cette semaine pour évoquer l affaire
gamestop nous sommes en liaison avec
anis lajnef bonjour vous êtes ancien
trader bienvenue dans ces caches oui
alors à nice pour commencer la votre
avis sur votre regard sur la sphère
gamestop le casse de l'année selon vous
pas si sûr comme le disait olivier juste
avant ces pratiques en fait elle se
faisait elle se fonde toujours la seule
différence c'est qu'avant se faisait
dans des on va dire des salons un peu
feutré de mes fers ou de new york est
que la l'organisation c'est à dire que
l'effet de foule s'est organisée sur des
réseaux sociaux donc c'est un peu la
version 3.0 de tout ce qui se faisait
avant c'est à dire des opérations
organisées entre investisseurs après
comme le disait olivier ce qui est
intéressant dans ce cas là c'est que
l'on veut on nous vend un peu le conte
de fées que c'est que des sardines qui
ont attaqué le requin ou des requins
n'est en fait je pense que parmi les
sardines y avait aussi des requins parce
que quand on voit comment ils ont créé
l'effet de levier c'est-à-dire comment
ils ont organisé leur stratégie par des
options et quand on voit aussi les
volumes qui sont traités il est certain
que ce n'est pas que des petits
investisseurs de robin août c'est à dire
qu'il y avait des requins qu'il était
déguisé en sardines et qui ont attaqué
justement les hedge-fund un peu vos
tours pour bien comprendre si c'est
c'est quelque chose qui s'est fait qui
s'est déjà fait qui se faisait pourquoi
est-ce que c'est là c'est cette affaire
là là ferguene stop qui dont tout le
monde parle pourquoi est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui qu'on parle de ça que c'est
avec cette affaire que ça
risen parce que avant ça se faisait
comme je le disais dans des salons
feutrés c'est à dire que c'est entre
gentleman et il n'y a pas de traces
parce que normalement c'est quasiment
interdit de travailler comme ça de
concert et d'aller manipulé des cours
et là ce qu'il ya c'est que ça a été
fait donc et une trace que ça a été fait
sur des forums comme celui de ray dit et
qu'il ya eu des gros poissons et même
des gens comme elon musk qui ont
justement chauffé à bloc
cette foule et ce qui s'est passé c'est
juste que c'est que c'est un mouvement
de foule de petits investisseurs qui ont
justement aider à pousser et à faire en
sorte que des plus gros fonds ou des
plus gros investisseurs gagne énormément
d'argent
d'accord olivier lafargue gamestop a
fait perdre au fonds d'investissement
selon le spécialiste des données
financières s trois partenaires jusqu'à
20 milliards de dollars on parle de 70
milliards du côté des chiffres fournis
fournis par au texte une entreprise
d'analysé financière des chiffres
vertigineux mais à relativiser c'est un
montant que le marché peut tout à fait
absorber a déclaré un responsable des
analyses économiques pour le cabinet de
conseil financier et j'ai à nos contrats
nos confrères de france 24 vous êtes
d'accord avec cela bah oui parce que
aujourd'hui ça ça représente une toute
petite partie de ce que met la banque
centrale tous les jours à disposition
donc et madame jelen
qui maintenant est directrice du trésor
a bien connu cette époque là enfin je
veux dire vous avez aujourd'hui des
milliards qui sont déversées tous les
jours sur les bourses par les banques
centrales donc en effet c'est pas parce
que d être fun perdent 70 milliards que
ça va changer la face du monde
non enfin réellement c'est ce que dit
annie cela c'est ça a été médiatisé ça a
été beaucoup médiatisé parce que pour
une fois cpct quasiment officiel et puis
qui a un certain nombre de alors moi je
le qualifie d' escroc comme elon musk
qui a fait tout ce qu'il a pu pour faire
monter la sauce et pourquoi très
probablement parce que il faisait partie
il peut il pourrait bien faire partie
des requins parmi les petites sardines
qui ont attaqué les elfes donc
et après ça s'est étendu ils ont il a
fait ça déjà plusieurs fois sur tesla
pour essayer de faire des short squeeze
il le fait maintenant sur le bitcoin
parce que le l'intérêt du bitcoin c'est
comme ça n'est pas un produit réguler et
bien vous n'avez aucun risque d'être
poursuivi pour manipulation de cours
et c'est bien pour ça que tous les gros
aujourd'hui poissons se sont mis sur le
beat pologne parce que ça leur permet de
manipuler les cours sans avoir de
problèmes avec la la sec ou tout autre
tout autre organisme de tutelle
et donc voilà on voit bien que c'est
quelque chose qui est favorisé par le
fait qu'il ya beaucoup de liquidités
et puis en plus par le fait que
certaines personnes un peu borderline
s'en sont emparés alors à nice lajnef à
la base en ces fonds spéculatifs on l'a
dit on parier sur la mort d'une
entreprise puisqu'ils ont parié sur la
baisse de l'action gamestop la mort
d'une entreprise cela signifie aussi des
pertes d'emploi des salariés sur le
carreau
alors d'un côté on à olivier le disais
avec les injections de liquidités de la
fête des spéculations à tout va de
l'autre on a ce genre de raid
est ce que finalement c'est pas un
terrain propice à une nouvelle crise
alors il ya un petit point qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que des hommes
gamestop on risque d'en revivre beaucoup
et on risque de revivre justement des
turbulences dans les marchés énormément
pourquoi parce que quand les banques
centrales comme la fed ou la bce à ger
ctt des milliards dans les marchés
financiers ce qu'ils font d'une certaine
façon c'est de faire baisser le
rendement des obligations
c'est à dire que moi je suis je veux
mettre mon argent dans une assurance-vie
ce qu'elle va faire le gestionnaire
c'est très simplement d'aller acheter
des obligations d'état comme celle de
l'est des états unis ou de l'allemagne
ou de la france
le problème c'est que quand ils
investissent dans de la dette française
ou allemande ils ont des rendements
négatifs et personne ne veut avoir des
rendements négatifs donc ce qu'ils vont
chercher c'est pour aller à avoir plus
de rendement de prendre un peu plus de
risques et ainsi de suite
ce qui va se passer c'est que les
investisseurs vont bouger
petit à petit de classes d'actifs pas
trop risqué à des classes d'actifs de
plus en plus risqué pour justement créer
du rendement donc ils vont aller vers
les actions ils vont aller vers les
produits dérivés
ils vont aller vers des fonds de fonds
et les fonds de fonds qu'est ce qu'ils
font les investisse justement dans ces
fonds spéculatifs qui font des raids sur
des sociétés ou qui utilisent énormément
d'effets de levier ou des produits
dérivés
il va y avoir plus de turbulences dans
les marchés en plomb vouloir que aux
politiques monétaires des banques
centrales seront eux qui ont justement
fait en sorte par leur politique
d'injecter des milliards et de faire en
sorte que les gens aillent chercher de
plus en plus du risque pour créer du
rendement et donc c'est un peu une ce
qu'on est en train de vivre les
symptômes d'un capitalisme financier
malade et donc un terrain propice à une
nouvelle crise a été de plus en plus de
crises en fait que ce que ce qu'ils ont
fait quand les banque centrale agisse
d'une telle façon qu'ils créent de
l'argent qui ne fait face à aucune
création de richesse ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire c'est de de la limite
d'être des alchimistes c'est-à-dire
qu'ils essaient de transformer le plomb
en or si l'économie est amorphe et ben
est amorphe et donc en mettant le risque
des dettes d'état à zéro ce qu'ils font
c'est juste transféré ce risque là vers
les actions et donc vers les produits
dérivés donc on va avoir de plus en plus
de mouvement et de turbulences sur les
marchés financiers et des histoires
comme gamestop ou sinon un mouvement de
marché vraiment fou c'est à dire qu'il
peut perdre la veine journée mois cinq
mois ci se reprendre plus 3 après ce
qu'on a vécu en mars dernier il faut
juste attendre le catalyst faut dire que
ma voir un catalyseur comme le virus
mais ça sera autre chose
olivier votre avis sur ce sujet cc je
suis tout à fait sur la même ligne le
clanisme et le
le pire pour les banques centrales c'est
que aujourd'hui elle elle se sent pêche
tout mouvement en arrière c'est à dire
que elles vont être obligés de continuer
pourquoi pas parce que vous avez en
effet tout le système qui part vers du
risque et donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'elles ne peuvent plus arrêter de
délivrer de la monnaie parce que si elle
arrête à ce moment là fin du jeu fin de
la musique le tout s'écroule et donc
elles vont être obligés de continuer à
vie c'est à dire que ces quelques jeux
c'est comme la drogue
ah si vous me couper brutalement le
shoot ça va pas aller donc le drogué va
être très très mal
eh bien là c'est la même chose c'est à
dire que vous êtes obligé de continuer
en permanence et on en rajoute ont à
chaque fois un peu plus parce que sinon
ça s'écroule et ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire aussi que on va avoir la même
politique à la fed qu'à la bce et que à
la banque d'angleterre et c c'est à dire
que vous allez avoir la même chose au
japon c'est-à-dire une banque centrale
qui va acheter des au tf qui va acheter
des actions qui va acheter des options
très probablement à un moment ou un
autre
parce qu'elle ne pourra pas faire
autrement parce que si elle s'arrête et
bien end of the game and his lajnef face
à ces actions à mener sur internet les
fameuses plateformes donc est tel que
robin route qui permettent donc assez
indépendant est d'investir en bourse ont
décidé le 28 janvier de limiter les
transactions notamment sur gamestop
certains membres de reddit ont crié à la
trahison ce sont leurs mots quand des
gens ordinaires essaie de se faire de
l'argent dans un système où d'habitude
ce ne sont que les riches qui en gagne
voilà ce qui se passe c'est ce qu'a
déclaré un membre actif du forum
wall street bête c'est vrai la question
se pose puisque finalement c'est fun
sont battus à leur propre jeu oui tout à
fait et alors toutes ses plateformes les
petites plates formes ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ils ont changé les
règles
au milieu de la partie et c'est comme si
en plein milieu d'un 100 mètres en
demandant un coureur qui a pris de la
vente mais qui n'était pas connu de
courir qu'elle sur pied droit c'est
alors est ce qu'on fait ce qu'a fait
robin où tu sais qu'il a demandé à tous
les petits investisseurs de ne plus
acheter
il avait juste le droit de vendre alors
c'est complètement nouveau ça on en
avait j'en avais jamais vu ce qu'on
appelle un
un bail sellings ban c'est à dire quoi
c'est une bague c'est l'interdiction
d'acheter parce que il n'ya rien de plus
naturel que d'acheter une action ce qui
n'est pas naturel que ces deux-là vendre
alors qu'on ne l'a pas ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est vraiment l'un vers s'avère
que le monde la finance marche sur la
tête c'est qu'ils ont interdit aux
petits investisseurs d'acheter encore là
l'action gamestop est donc ce qui s'est
passé c'est que à mon avis c'est même
pas ma vie puisque ces publics
il ya la chambre de compensation qui a
tiré les oreilles robin hood qui lui a
demandé 3 milliards de dollars et donc
robin wood a dû aller voir ses
investisseurs et levier en catastrophe
un milliard de dollars pour continuer
justement dans la partie et aussi ce qui
s'est passé c'est que citadelle qui est
le principal qui de robin hood puisque
robin hood en fait ne charge pas de
frais aux petits parce que ce sont eux
les produits ils sont payés par des ddd
broker en ligne ou des brokers comme
citadelle où des êtres humains comme
citadelle qui eux soit allé voir rob et
nous devons en tirer un peu les oreilles
pour que justement il met il change les
règles en gros plan en plein milieu de
la partie et donc c'est pour ça que les
petits investisseurs vivent ça comme une
injustice parce que je suis conseiller
groupe bien sûr quand les gros il gagne
on laisse les règles du jeu telles
qu'elles sont et concis les petits d'un
seul coup dites à tous on a on a tous
ces grands lacs qui se réunissent et qui
disent non on peut pas il ya un
milliardaire québec qui agit sur qui a
parlé sur 'cnbc' et qui est vraiment
c'est plein de tous ces petits pauvres
qui embête les riches dans leur business
et donc oui c'est on est on est on est
face à une injustice par exemple tous
les petits robin hood en mal en donner
mauvaise note sur google à la plateforme
en ligne robineau débat google a annulé
toutes ses mauvaises notes
c'est à dire quand on se rend compte que
tout ce monde de 2,2 possédant s'est
liguée contre les petits investisseurs
c'est comme ça en tout cas que je le
vois mais si on va marquer une courte
pause en verre dans un instant bienvenue
dans ses cages si vous nous rejoignez au
sommaire cette semaine la sphère et
gamestop et pour cela nous sommes en
liaison avec anicet lajnef ancien trader
olivier des sénateurs américains
notamment bernie sanders et elizabeth
warren ont appelé à réformer wall street
elizabeth warren par exemple demande un
marché plus transparent et ouvert aux
investisseurs indépendant bernie sanders
lui elle dénonce je cite le comportement
scandaleux des fonds est
d'investissement est ce qu'il faudrait
penser effectivement à revoir le mode de
fonctionnement de wall street et si oui
comment
si vous voulez mon avis moi si je si
j'étais aux manettes
je remettrai une cotation par jour parce
que du coup ça tuerait tout ce qui est
saturé une bonne partie de la
spéculation et probablement limités au
plus strict les effets de levier
on sait très bien eux à cause de ses
effets de levier
combien d'êtres contestions actuellement
audigier pardon combien il ya de
cotation il y en a c'est tout au long de
la journée et donc vous en avez
maintenant à la nano secondes puisque
vous avez des trading haute fréquence
il fonce à la nano secondes alors
excusez-moi mais la valeur d'une société
ne change pas en une nanoseconde c'est
pas vrai donc vous pourriez très bien
remettre un fixing par jour et ça se
passerait extrêmement bien parce qu'on
reviendrait en fait à ce qu était la
bourse au départ la bourse au départ
c'est un endroit où les sociétés qui
étaient cotées pouvait se financer
d'accord soit par augmentation de
capital soit et donc soit par crédit par
obligation et vous aviez un marché
secondaire qui permettait de s'échanger
des types mais vous n'aviez pas tout la
spéculation qu'on a mis avec des effets
de levier qui et qui sont aujourd'hui
gigantesque vous aviez dans certaines
dans certaines sociétés
vous avez des effets de levier qui vont
jusqu'à 80 fois donc c'est ridicule donc
on sait très bien que ce qui va se
passer parce qu'un jour il ya un pépin
est là pour le coup vous perdez beaucoup
plus que ce que vous avez mis donc si on
veut réellement protéger et protéger
tout le monde c'est-à-dire les aussi
bien les gros que les petits eh bien il
faut revenir à quelque chose de plus
raisonnable parce que là aujourd'hui
c'est un gros casinos ça n'a rien à voir
avec ce que ça a été en bourse je pense
pas à nice a été trader il ya quelques
il ya quelques années comme moi qui
étais traders il ya il ya 20 ans 30 ans
vous n'êtes pas le même métier que font
les traders aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous
n'avez absolument plus d' analyse ou
quoi que ce soit c'est des programmes
trading c'est du trading à haute
fréquence ça n'a rien à voir avec de la
bourse et ça a plus à voir avec du
casino justement année c'est la jeunesse
vous qui êtes ancien trader est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ces propositions
de l'évier ah oui tout à fait en fait je
rajouterais même quelque chose déjà si
on mettait juste une une taxe de 0,05
pour cent qui est quasiment rien dans
mon curé le trading haute fréquence
c'est à dire le trading qui h à ti qui
vint une action en moins d'une seconde
et même ça se rende défend nanoseconde
donc il ya un moyen de de réguler un peu
ce casino c'est à dire que on peut faire
un peu mal aux algues aux ago traders
aux traders haute fréquence juste en
incluant une toute petite taxe
après quant à l'effet de levier c'est
c'est c'est un peu comme ça que marche
la bourse de le jour c'est que on n'a
rien appris de la crise de 29
1929 c'est que on repart dans ce set
cette bourse qui n'est pas au service de
l'économie mais qui est au service
d'elle-même que au service de la finance
c'est à dire que on est capable de
démultiplier sa capacité à parier dans
les marchés est une alors je vais juste
si je peux parler d'une seule chose de
nos jours olivier a dit mme gladys
essais c'était mon cas moi par exemple
pendant la crise de 2008 c'est que quand
une entreprise allait mal elle ne se
retournait pas vers l'état pour mendier
des milliards c'est à l'aller vers les
actionnaires pour lever de l'argent
c'est à dire c'est ce qu'on appelle une
augmentation de capital
de nos jours ces gens il sont drogués à
la morphine monétaire gratuite et est ce
qu'ils font c'est que quand ils ont
besoin d'argent ils vont et ils vont
profiter des milliards qui sont déversés
par la fed et la bce pour se financer et
on arrive à quelque chose qui devient
mais presque ubuesque c'est que on
rentre dans une période de cabine et
cannibalisme financiers c'est à dire que
avant il faisait d augmente
son capital de nos jours les entreprises
font exactement le contraire lnh est
elle par dont elle emprunte gratuitement
de l'argent
c'est ce que fait par exemple lvmh avec
bernard arnault mais quasiment toutes
les multinationales le fond et
multinationales françaises
elle emprunte pour pas cher pour acheter
leurs propres actions et 1 6l et les
détruire après notablement et c'est ce
qu'on appelle le rachat d'actions et
c'est ce qui fait monter justement les
bourses énormément c'est ce cannibalisme
financier qui est le rachat d'actions et
qui n'est pas encore légiféré c'est à
dire qu'on laisse faire donc on nous
vend la fable que tous les milliards qui
sont injectés dans les marchés
financiers servent l'économie réelle et
sert et devrait servir l'emploi mais ce
n'est pas vrai ça sert la finance ça
sert à ce que les multinationales grain
pour au ciel et ça sert à ce que les pdg
et les et les grands salariés de ces
multinationales s'en mettre plein les
poches
voilà à quoi ça sert tout certains à
l'argent injecté par les banques
centrales et ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup à nice lajnef d'avoir été
parmi nous a dans cette émission je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien trader
olivier nous on continue avec les
questions cash
et on commence tout de suite avec la
question de james 68 le plan de relance
de byden va-t-il vraiment être suffisant
pour relancer l'économie
bien sûr que non bien sûr que non les
plans de relance sont d'ailleurs pas
destiné à ça on l'a on l'a dit là il ya
deux minutes avec l'argent qu'ils
étaient déversées par les banques
centrales les plans de relance ça sert à
maintenir une illusion de redémarrage et
croissance mais ça n'a jamais servi
depuis depuis quasiment 2008 ça n'a
jamais servi à relancer l'économie
réelle
on passe à la question de julien le plan
de relance de bail donne prévoit un
volet vers la relance verte est elle la
clé j'ai pas je suis pas sûr que il
suffit de mettre une couleur pour que un
plan de relance marche vous aurez le
plan de relance bleu rouge vert ça n'a
aucune incidence
cissé c'est toujours la même chose si
vous voulez le l'étape
relancer les choses en investissant mais
si c'est un investissement intelligent
est réel si c'est pour nous je l' ai dit
plusieurs fois en france si c'est pour
nous construire des éoliennes qui ne
fonctionne pas qui donne qui sont dont
l'électricité est racheté trois fois le
prix par par edf et qui sont polluantes
comme comme jamais c'est pas intelligent
et ça ne vous relancera pas le
l'économie donc voilà c'est toujours le
c'est toujours la même chose alors on
essaie d'étiqueter un plan en dix ans
quand les tic temps ça va devenir
merveilleux non c'est pas merveilleux
aussi plan est nul
le plan est nul qu'ils soient verts
rouges ou bleues merci beaucoup olivier
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
votre fidélité prochain rendez vous est
la semaine prochaine et puis rendez vous
sur notre site internet pour découvrir
nos précédentes émissions et n'oubliez
pas être poser toutes vos questions à
olivier sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag rt cash ou en commentaire et des
vidéos et puis olivier on se quitte avec
votre mot de la fin est bien écouter
avant la sardine bouché le port de
marseille aujourd'hui elle fait couler
des hedge fund